ces recruteurs sont des représentants
d'entreprises mais aussi des
associations ou des coopératives à la
recherche de jeunes recrues à la
verrière une douzaine d'entreprises de
partenaires étaient présents
objectif sensibiliser les jeunes à
l'économie sociale et solidaire et
parler des emplois proposés par le
secteur nous avons la possibilité
d'offrir des emplois divers qualifiés et
nous permettons nous permettons aussi à
nos employés de pouvoir évoluer à
l'intérieur le couple ça recrute mais
aussi il ya aussi certaine méfiance un
vis-à-vis aussi des entreprises
donc c'est aussi pouvoir montrer aux
entreprises que avec le social et
l'insertion on peut aussi avancer
ensemble et faire de belles choses à
voir de très beaux parcours et de
réussite
selon l'observatoire régional de
l'économie sociale et solidaire en
ile-de-france cette économie en plein
essor emploie près de 33 mille personnes
dans les yvelines
pourtant les moins de 25 ans ne
représentent que 7% de ses salariés paul
veut travailler dans le développement
durable et traoré dans le domaine de
l'électricité
ils ont tous les deux passé plusieurs
entretiens m'ont dit qu'ils allaient
transmettre non savez adhérents twitter
et dont on dit que le sauver il était
bien donc une j'attends la réponse
on a vu pour l'année 2015 la création de
deux postes sur l'emploi aidé et donc la
plus orientée sur le thème du
développement durable donc un peu plus
adapté à mon profil ils vont décider ça
en interne
durant le mois de décembre début janvier
et donc je me retournais vers eux à ce
moment là où ils seraient des réponses
concrètes financées actions associatives
sont et de nombreuses activités de
l'économie sociale et solidaire propose
des emplois dans les yvelines le taux de
chômage chez les jeunes de catégorie à
s'élève à 15%